boy not whoever takes over the chair
will really deepen that point yep
okay it's just loading up now okay thank
you the only absence I've heard the
notified series George Ribble I've got
some as well so I can get them out okay
okay we're now live on YouTube welcome
to the Oviatt Whitney Whitney being held
actually live streamed on YouTube the
first item is the apologies for absence
and I have counsel the Gribble counselor
Keely and counselor Lorraine heaven
before we start the meeting I just do
roll call so the members can confirm
that they are president so when I read
your name you could go just indicate
that you're here then you've got a
record of the attendance so councillor
Austin because Rosten are you here can
you indicate can you take your
microphone off mute please
helps Rustin so so every anybody that's
just listening can confirm that as well
yes yep
thank you and then he that's rotten if
you can put your microphone back on mute
again Thank You Council of Bullivant
present counselor Sheila cook apologies
councillor David Cox present absent
counselor Hume ACOG's
present counselor
Richard doors yes I'm here thank you
counselor Alison Eden has read and sorry
I didn't hear that
mm-hmm okay thank you it counts
counselor Alison folk then yes counselor
Linden
Linda Goodman robbery present counsel of
your pays present counselor Mike Hawking
yeah
counselor Sally Morgan present counselor
Liam alone yeah counselor John nutley
present counselor Charles not all
[Music]
counselor Jackie or present present okay
cats no Sarah Parker Khan present
counselor Adrian patch cancel a patch
counselor and Robert present counselor
John Patrick resident counselor Linda
Patrick present counselor Steve and
purser present counselor
Dave Ralston present cancel it build
thorne
I don't counselor Terry - Terry - no I
can I just check it council later and
patch isn't present today and I think
actually my giving this apology say
thank you the first item on this you did
miss me on the roll call counselor jinx
sorry I can't sir James me yeah that's
fine second item on the agenda is to
elect a chair for the following year
could I have nominations nice good I
nominate counselor for the all of them
please and have I got a seconder for
counselor
councillor David Cox so their proposal
was a counselor Steve on purser seconder
with councillor David Cox okay so we
need to now take a vote on to discern
the confirm the Chairman as councillor
dill Bullivant I'll go through the go
Scooby
roll corn just to confirm though
councillor barrel Austin for you say
there councillor David Cox
yes can still a hue cogs yep can still
adores yes counselor Alison Eden yes
counselor Faden yes counselor Linden
good Linda Goodman Bradbury for council
Rob haze or cancer the mic Hawking
counselor Chris Jonas for cancer Sally
Morgan oh that's a little Liam alone
against counselor John Knightley or
counselor Charles nettle cantaloupes
Jackie or Paul Sarah pocket on Robert
that's what John plethoric counselor
Linda Patrick full axilla Stephen purser
for cats lair
Dave Wallace den or counselor
Thor that's Carrie congratulations
and then I'll hand over you to chair the
rest of the meeting okay thank you very
much everybody
right there's official notice would you
please make sure that all microphones
are muted when you're not speaking to
avoid any background noise levels and
please could you keep any point short
and do not interrupt when somebody is
speaking if you wish to comment please
you raise your electronic blue hands
wait to be call when it comes to the
vote the democratic service officer will
read out members names would members
please say if they are voting for
against or abstaining if my video link
goes down with there will automatically
pass the Dave Cox who take or sorry will
pass to the vice-chair so the next item
on the agenda is the election of the
vice chair can I propose Dave Cox please
could I have a seconder for that a
second we have a second
Sturridge you want to go through a vote
yes [ __ ] next with the fav are there
any other nominations I have nobody
indicating there are any other
nominations
can I take it therefore there's a
unanimous vote for a Dave Cox the
sitting vice chair thank you and I said
you still want to take that thank you
okay well congratulations David and
welcome on board now you say that the
offices today that are present on Neal
Blaney the strategic lead for headed
place and Commercial Services Michelle
Luscombe principal planning policy
officer Alex les where senior planning
policy officer Tony Manso recovery
project officer and he was going to be
Trish corns democratic services offices
but obviously Trish's got some problems
with the instant connections we also
have guests with us from guests and the
guests are Catherine Smith George
Marshall will Pratt and Erin Beecham and
throws people will be available to
answer questions should you have them on
the guest presentation so I'm moving now
to the minutes of our last meeting which
took place back in March
remember eight are there any questions
about the minutes as printed I have no
one raising any question what I would
like to draw to your attention on minute
number 30
we word you to receive a house eating
target report from counsel his portfolio
Oleg Eric Taylor counter Taylor would
you like to say anything about that
particular or a minute which is slamming
oh I'm sorry Gary I'll be earring thank
you Thank You chair yes yes certainly
and it was proposed of course that we
write a letter to the government to ask
about the standard method of calculation
to the best of my knowledge we haven't
received any response that will give us
an indication that the review is coming
forward anytime soon
we await their we wait await
confirmation on that they do confirm
that letter assembly required
indeed okay thank you very much next I
there was a further query on the next
item which was minute 31 poverty in
Cambridge leader if you have any issues
or questions you'd like to click with
that one do I have any answers or
questions I was - me - yes - okay okay
first of all I didn't thirty I can
confirm that a letter was sent under my
name from the Council on March the 4th
subsequent to the request from ons of
March the 3rd to the minister we have
not had a reply to that letter but
another letter from me is sitting on the
minister's desk awaiting a response
seeking a response to the original
letter so we live in hope I do think
that probably to be fair to the
government they have willing to other
things on their mind of late and it just
might have caused the prioritization
have wanted to other things
secondly I think you know moving on to
the question of the pie the teaser right
item 31 there was a report to come back
to the committee
setting up ports requesting that we set
up a task and finish group right nothing
is yet been submitted so coming
expect that in the near future yeah the
situation there is that the request was
made just before we put a third or more
of the staff on furlough just before
lockdown and this particular piece of
important work will be picked up under
the recovery work which we got to touch
on later on in the agenda the the in
terms of reference of that recovery work
include poverty in Cambridge we as an
authority are working closely with the
voluntary sector with CBS and so on but
because of a significant reduced officer
time and availability over the last
three or four months which I'm sure
everybody understands it's been
difficult to justify adding this
workload to an over stretched and work
force it will be picked up it is
important we are keen to proceed with it
but it will be part of the recovery
programme which we're going to look at
later on in the agenda I hope that helps
that's great thank you for that
clarification Nellie moving on minute
number 35 fly-tipping that was a
question that counts the Dewhurst with
you to come back on he has apologized
and explained that we'll have something
for the September meeting as we go
forward
Millia thirty-six toxic non toxic week
Control Council McGregor you have
anything to add to that the comments
made by by councillor Hook in terms of
staff being furloughed and not only were
over 150 staff from from from from my
portfolio on furlough the grounds
maintenance team for Ida Verde a
groundsman contractors were also
furloughed as a cost-saving exercise
during the same period as a result of
that we haven't had a chance to fully
evaluate other alternative options
although we have started now to evaluate
one or two options and we are taking
reports from other locations across the
country about
the other alternatives and a report will
be forthcoming it's in September for
that
taking opportunity at this stage to
thank all of the officers those
including those who went on furlough and
were patient while we went through this
crisis but particularly the ones who
remained in post who took on an
incredible workload and managed to
maintain services throughout the period
well thank you for that and so September
we will get something coming back from
you counsel Mariette yes thank you for
that right moving on then are you all
happy that subject to those answers
going back in you're happy with the
minutes of the meeting that took place
in September in March could you please
indicate by chopin's that you accept you
that's all
okay there's anybody that disagrees with
that or anybody not taking a position on
those myths can they therefore take it
that those minutes are approved
counselor Bullivant I see the doors
raise his hand yeah um obviously I
haven't got the screen on okay counselor
doors
is there any issue you wants to raise or
point out brace boy I raised my hand to
the question there's anyone not taking
the position on those minutes I see okay
thank you very much indeed
apart from their counter doors I take it
in everybody else happy those that would
like to point out that the report about
counts Adrienne patchi's 5tp obviously
he's no round and as I understand have
been able to contact him with darling
what we need that report and I hope we
can bring that report because it's an
important matter to the September
meeting and perhaps they'll also add
civil recovery because we're finding
people when the fines don't even we
don't get this money from the fines and
the fines don't cover the cost
not people with rubbish who fly tip so I
do think the council should consider a
civil action as part of that fly-tipping
report to deal with people who are
irresponsible news our recycling areas
is places to dump televisions chairs and
furniture guy suggests therefore if that
is a request that we extend the the
brief could you take on board the
submission of the appropriate to
paperwork so it can become a custom
finish groups all go thank you
I take it those counts of course yes
yeah like they thank you
right so having approve those minutes
can we move on with the rest of meeting
in any other in declarations of
interests relative to items we'll be
discussing later on today I have no
indications of anybody with declarations
of interest there are no two items
within today's discussion we have can I
just confirm that we have received no
public questions please Sarah no public
questions received thank you and in
terms of councillor questions have we
received in it I haven't received any
councillors questions thank you and we
have no callings no cornets thank you
no case we move on to item 9 which is
the review of the Greater Exeter
strategic plan document that is intended
to go out to public scrutiny I think
there's a great deal of uncertainty
amongst the councils involved about the
future figure but nonetheless we want to
go out what the council wants to go out
to establish the public view may be mine
all councillors that had the opportunity
to take part in the pre discussion
groups those will continue this is
purely an exercise to go out for it to
obtain the public input into that
document so what I'd like to do is first
of all in by Gary Taylor to introduce
the subject he will then pass over to
the officer Michelle Erskine the
principal planning all
the officer to present the presentment
report can idea for us a gallery tailor
to introduce Michelle lustre mr.
chairman members of the overview and
scrutiny committee thank you very much
for the opportunity today to introduce
item 9 on the agenda the Greater
Exorcist strategic plan draft policies
and site options consultation report to
seek your positive recommendation to the
executive committee to approve the
documentation to go forward for public
consultation and to hold a further call
for sites as set out on pages 13 and 14
it is almost four years since team
bridge joined forces with Exeter East
Devon and Mid Devon councils to bring
forward together the Greater extra
strategy plan before us now such a
strategic plan has three major strengths
the first is that it satisfies the duty
to cooperate with neighboring
authorities on planning matters a
requirement under the government's
national planning policy framework the
NPP f without which any local plan or
plan review would fail the second is the
generation of a sufficient critical mass
to attract investment from government
backed agencies such as homes England
who are providing funding for local road
building and garden community's
initiatives from major service and
infrastructure providers such as
Southwest water and Western power and
from Network Rail who has recently
announced new stations at Wellington and
at Columbia in Mid Devon with more
expected soon to follow
the third strengths is that those
overarching policies that affect all of
our areas can be more rigorously
prepared policies such as those covering
action on climate change where of course
team bridge has taken a lead and others
such as the conservation of habitats and
species at European sites such as the
south hands si si
the X s 3s PA and the East Devon
pebble-bed Heath it is also important to
bear in mind that while the combined
numbers in guest are significant no
additional housing burden over and above
that
mandated by the government standard
method is placed upon us while sites
have been selected through an
unconstrained methodology focusing on
existing and potentially and potential
sustainable transport loads housing
numbers that are above any local
authority target guests sake that is
we've served to reduce allocations
within each local planning authority
area
conversely removing a guess site
increases the requirement elsewhere in
that district potential allocations
coming forward through the fresh call
for sites process I very much hope this
process will generate not just
Greenfield but further brownfield sites
for consideration also with the full
local planning authorities having
renewed their vows at last summer
following following Mays local elections
the work on guess which has included
spatial mapping workshops regular
leadership meetings and member reference
forums has continued apace and while
lockdown has of course meant a delay the
extensive draws guess reports policies
and plan documentation we see today
serve as a credit to all those console
T's and stakeholders members and
officers past and present who have
contributed towards their completion mr.
chairman members I would like to commend
this report to you for your positive
recommendation but before then with your
permission I would like to call upon our
lead officer Michelle Luscombe to tell
you more about the reports and about the
guests teeth team staffing and financial
considerations going forward for which
we also seek your recommendation today
and which can be found at appendix F
attached on pages 29 to 31 thank you
thank you
councilors Taylor and councilor
Bullivant can you hear me okay
okay I'm just going to share my screen
with you oh um sorry Sara apparently I
can't oh thank you
Thanks okay okay so this report asked
members to consider the draft policies
and site options of the great Exeter
strategic plan and to recommend the
executive that is approved for an
eight-week period of consultation which
will start in September we just sort of
be useful to run through the background
of the Greater extra strategic plans
they're not the content of the plan
itself but more of the context in which
the plan has been established and
highlight some key bits of information
that you might find helpful in
considering this recommendation
so firstly and I'm sure you're all aware
of this but just to cover it and make
sure everyone is is aware of what the
Greater Exeter strategic plan is this is
the strategic development plan that is
being prepared jointly by ourselves a
team bridge east Devon Exeter and mid 7
and also in partnership with Devon
County Council so it will cover the
period from 2020 to 2040 in contrast to
our local plan which deals with the
detailed local planning matters such as
design parking standards householder
development and that were there with
smaller scale development allocations
the greater extra strategic plan will
address the big strategic matters in the
Greater Exeter area the reason we're
doing this is because people and places
don't stop at political boundaries we
share infrastructure and environments
and the city of Exeter obviously
connects us all with many job
opportunities as well as the major
leisure health and shopping facilities
within the wider area the joint approach
means that there are more opportunities
to coordinate better planning so through
doing this we can look for the most
sustainable locations for development
across the wider area we can jointly
target investment in key infrastructure
including our sustainable transport
links and digital connectivity and also
ensure the environmental protection for
our wildlife sites in particularly
excess Jerry which crosses three
administrative boundaries we've been
working on this plan with the support of
Holmes England and they are helping us
actively to promote the greater extra
brand with the aim of bringing in
significant government investment to the
Greater extra region and this is
important because it will help us to
fund the infrastructure that we need
alongside the new development so that we
can really help to achieve the high
quality places that we want within the
Greater extra area
[Music]
this diagram here just the right and
useful context and how the great extra
strategic plan fits into all the other
plans that we're preparing so together
all these plans show the development
plan 14 bridge and when we get in any
application for development we will
assess it against the relevant
development plan or plans so our future
development plan in team bridge once
adopted will be made up of the Greater
extra strategic plan the local plans
part 1 and part 2 any adopted
neighborhood plans and the Devon waste
and minerals plans which are prepared by
Devon County Council so as mentioned
earlier just covering sort of what the
guest is going to contain the guests
will be strategic in nature and by this
we mean allocations for large employment
sites and housing developments which
would typically be above 500 homes the
threshold is lower within the city of
Exeter but outside Exeter the the
threshold is 500 hangsen above so the
draft policies and site options document
includes a range of options as to where
these can be most sustainably located
it's important to note that not all of
the options will be then taken forward
into the proposed submission version
there are more options within this plan
then we will need it within the final
plan and all of these options have been
chosen on the basis of those which have
the best connections to services and
infrastructure and transport links and
the least impact on the environment in
terms of policies this plan is looking
at those issues affect more than one of
the districts and therefore has
cross-boundary implications or benefits
in particular it's reflecting our
collective strong ambitions to meet the
challenges of climate change so we've
got various other documents that are
also appended to the report today and
these are also subject to your approval
these include two environmental reports
there the sustainability appraisal
habitats regulation assessment these are
both legal requirements for plan making
and they'll be available to comment on
as part of the consultation there's a
consultation statement as well which
explains how all of the comments which
were made during the first stage of
consultation so that was the issues
consultation back in 2017 how they've
been taken into account and there's also
an inequality impact assessment which
shows the potential impacts of the plan
on protected groups so all of these
documents and the various evidence
reports that have been used to prepare
the plan will be available on the guest
web site subject to approval by all four
partner authorities this consultation is
expected to begin in September given the
likelihood of extended social distancing
restrictions it's likely that this will
be a largely virtual consultation or
those face-to-face events will be
arranged if it's appropriate to do so
it's worth just noting that anyone
that's unsure about whether we can
effectively engage with people virtually
just to note the success that we've had
in the recent local plan consultation
which closed yesterday the latest
consultation generated over three and a
half times as many formal consultation
responses of our previous issues
consultation did back in 2018 and
through social social media we've
reached over 50,000 people with our
online videos and posts which is more
than ten times the amount reached in
2018 the next item on the agenda also
discusses the statement of community
involvement I won't go into that in
detail right now but that sets out the
principles on which engagement will take
place and it's hopefully
self-explanatory within the report
itself
so if recommended today to the executive
and approved by the executive and all of
the other authorities as well this will
be the second form of stage of
consultation on the guest
we aim to publish on the 21st of
September for an eight-week consultation
period which will end on the 16th of
November because of the kovat 19 related
delays we do need to revisit the overall
timetable for the guests but will bring
a further report back to the executive
in due course on this so the plan as it
stands is the product of three years of
engagement with our communities
landowners specialist consultants and
district members the plan has been
overseen an officer level by the project
advisory group and principals which are
the chief executives of the four
district authorities it's also been
overseen politically to the leadership
group which is comprised of all leaders
and portfolio holders for planning
across the four district to authorities
and the members of the guests member
reference for and so that's comprised of
ten cross party members from each each
local planning authority their current
leaders seeing reports being taken to
all four partner authorities to seek
approval for consultation in September
it was agreed by exeter at a meeting
last week and will be going through a
seven and mid demand committees in this
month so any minor amendments today
which are sought will be noted and
they'll be discussed by the leadership
groups again service the group made up
of the leaders and portfolio holders and
they'll be discussing any proposals from
minor amendments and so anything that
doesn't really go to the heart of the
plan on the 28th of august however if
you do feel there are matters of any
detail which would welcome further
discussion on and we would welcome your
feedback on this during the consultation
period and and we're proposing that we
use the local plan working group which
is already established as a forum to
provide all members with the opportunity
to discuss the plan in detail and
officers will be available to talk about
the each of each of the different
aspects of the plan
so we'll send notifications out when
these meetings will be taking place and
all members of the local plan working
group and the guest member reference
forum will be invited to it and then it
will also be advertised via the members
newsletter so that's it for the
presentation and our Humbert TD
cancelable event and if you have any
further questions on this or the rest of
the report then please let me know thank
you I therefore ask the committee for
any comments or questions that they may
have councillor doors doors hello thank
you thanks for the presentation Michelle
it was interesting to see the on the
cover of the greater Exorcist
Easter ways that wonderful development
in broad Hampsten that that we are all
so proud of in the district to be
representative of the housing that will
be delivered it should have been a
Lyndon Holmes development with 16 houses
squeezed on each acre I'll note the
success of the social media campaign for
consultation on the local plan I'll also
note that three parish councils who I
represent CPRA Devon and the Wilbur
Residents Association have written to
teamriche District Council giving
serious concerns about carrying out
consultation in a unprecedented pandemic
and that it disadvantages certain
individuals who've possibly not legally
compliant they requested an extension
which I understand has not been given
the greater extra strategic plan here's
a pan that was dreamt up in the pre
Covent world
it's ill thought through from start to
finish you does not represent the very
best interests
the residents from my understanding can
I have sat on one or two meetings or
from the committee elected to represent
my residents the purpose of it is to
shoulder the weight of Exeter's
ambitious growth targets more ambitious
than china and and for those housing
developments to be foisted on to east
ever mid devon and temperature my
understanding also is that the greater
extra strategic plan has been driven
from team bridge and by team bridge i
cannot say it's in the best interest of
the residents i think the district
deserves a better plan were builds the
right houses in the right location I
would implore English District Council
and all members to recognize that we're
in a joint emergency of climate change
in Kovach 19 and set about creating a
plan once those once the initial
pandemic has settled down and we
understand what the post Kovach world is
and the plan that holds the awful and
dreadful the Salton Devon that's been
undertaken by this council and other
councils over the last 10 to 15 years
thank you I think it comes the doors are
there anybody else wishing to make
comments or wish to ask any questions
please I would like to make a comment
councillor Jenks could you use the blue
hand please if you wish to erase
question yeah Thank You chair
and I would just like to ask officers if
after the public consultation has ended
will there be a report that you'll put
together exactly where you'll take into
consideration what change it what direct
changes the public comments have made
within a future plan so you know in the
forms of us being as transparent as
possible and listening to the people of
our community will there be a separate
report to show exactly where those
changes will be implemented
thank you can I ask Chancellor Taylor to
respond to that please
Thank You Jay I think Michelle Lasker
would probably be in a better position
to respond to that question
okay scan Michelle would you like to
respond future problem and yes cancer
Jenks it's a statue requirement that we
have to prepare a consultation statement
for each stage of the plan making so one
of the appendices to the report this on
this agenda is reflecting how the
consultation responses were taken into
account from the 2017 consultation and
then similarly when we published the
next stage of consultation we will have
a detailed summary of everybody's
comments our responses to them and how
the plan has been amended in response to
those thank you thank you council Malone
you have a question yeah and since the
so called renewal of valves on this just
after the 2019 May elections there has
been a considerable change of power at
least Evan and the people who are there
now have vocalized they're extremely
patient to to the strategic and going so
far sometimes as to say they're
considering pulling out of it it's it's
no secret that my group very much hopes
they do that because we think it's a
unmitigated catastrophe for everyone
involved and particularly for the
environment but notwithstanding that is
it not better in terms of time and money
being spent to wait and see we plan to
do thank you for that cancer tailored
you under one set or shall I pass it
straight to Michelle well I think
there's a simple answer I think it's no
I think we do need to move ahead we've
we've taken four years to get to this
point with we've lost some time through
October 19 unfortunately we we need to
make
but otherwise we could find ourselves in
this situation we are we know currently
that our outputs on housing is much much
lower than it should be those figures
feed into our five-year land supply and
we could find that although currently we
do have a five year at land supply which
won't won't put us in a situation where
developers can nominate sites as being
as being automatically sustainable me if
therefore get planning permission to
build on them we might be in that
situation in 12 months time so so there
is a lot of pressure to move ahead with
with this plan so that we can feed it
into our part two of the local plan that
we're that we are preparing to make sure
that we can satisfy the five-year
housing land supply which the government
require of us thank you and councillor
Hawking yeah Thank You chair I found
myself in a position actually I find
myself agreeing when you assess know
which is a strange one but they ever
since the gasp has been brought about I
have always been very worried that ting
Ridge would have imposed upon it
something that ting breeze doesn't
particularly want doesn't need and
certainly another as a growing area
would be at the Bennett would not be at
the benefit of anything that comes to
Washington Bridge and this is been
proven correct yet again nickname has
been single singled out for a huge
development which we built on to the to
the side of the already important
development which is Winifred planet at
the moment and we cannot take any more
hoses the hoses
greed within the tune bridge local plan
which is now being reviewed as we know
was more than what the people really
wanted at the very beginning but we all
will be or with that and these
developments that are in the local plan
at the moment the timber is local at the
moment will come about and we know that
I'll be accepted that I think a little
bit there is still some issues over na3
but certainly na one I think will find
that that will now go forward and if any
three I believe also will go forward the
respect of what happens and that's where
a Newton of Newton says no probably
disagree mate what I do welcome within
this plan is the is the employment side
of it ting bridge as a deep as a
planning authority and with their local
plan has not brought forward the
employment that they should have done
which was which was within the plan and
he still within the plan but of course
the guests are now saying that that will
come forward which I believe is a good
thing but we cannot and we should not
accept any more any more houses other
than what's already in within our plan
anything
it says the soap under on page 19 so
security and strategic growth area then
it states there that Newton Abbot King
st. makings curves will create a
certificate and significant employment
and housing area it is void urban area
with good transport things that they
come to Newton of it lately I don't
think they have yes we have a train
station we have a we have a bus lay by
place it's not a bus station it's a and
the young the actual public transport
using that bus there is very poor you
can go to Torquay beautiful you can even
go to an Exeter beautiful but not at the
right times when you want to go to work
okay
this is no bus is running um
there's the trains yes all right
are good but you try getting from home
important or real part to the railway
station you could have good food never
and we all know how bad Newt nowadays I
believe we've got to saturation point
within Nunavut I would not want to see
any more as if we Kosovo I shall be
voting against I think this is
ill-prepared and not wanting can I thank
you for that for reckons that to other
people asking questions council Petric
Linda metric my question comes from what
counts and Malone said and but he's
definitely about pulling out I mean my
question is is that correct and if so
what would happen to the plan if they
did the future of the plan if they did
thank you I can never pass this the two
questions to Michele Luskin there's got
also got a hand raised Michelle yes and
thank you
council Bullivant I just thought I'd
pick up on a couple of points that have
been made there by council Hawkings and
Heatherette doors I'm alone and so first
one response council of Heather X and
obviously we don't know what the
situation will be in a seven and they
haven't had their committee meeting yet
I think we you know we act as our own
Council at the moment and make our own
decisions and if they choose to not vote
the plan through then we would have to
go back to the leadership group and it
would be for them to decide the best way
in which they want to move forward or
amend the plan or understand exactly you
know what the issues are that's made
east evan if they do decide to vote
against it to do that but i think at the
moment that's an unknown and we like to
say we just have to make our own
decision today on what what we feel is
best 14 bridge in terms of exeter and
the suggestion
that we're taking Exeter's housing need
I think it's clear through the plan and
the report that extra is meeting its own
housing needs there isn't a suggestion
here that how do you have the need to be
employed elsewhere so extra have a very
ambitious brownfield regeneration
program that showing around 12,000
houses being built within the city
itself so there isn't any implication on
that for the rest of the authorities
there and in fact the whole premise on
which at Greater extra plan is built is
that actually as I said in my
presentation people and places don't
stop at political boundaries and
Pembridge have very sensitive
environment which has been acknowledged
and comparative for the 18 bridge has
much fewer sites that are currently
proposed through this options document
which does propose larger scale
developments largely because of our
constraints our minerals our
environmental sensitivities and and also
the infrastructure links as you get more
out towards the peripheries so and also
describe again this is an options
consultation what's really important is
that we get this out there into the
public so that we can start talking
about it we can start having these open
and honest debates of our communities
because the housing need is not going
away and whilst we have to acknowledge
our climate change issues which is a
fundamental part of this plan and
essential if we want to start tackling
the climate emergency that we do get
these and consistent policies in place
across the broader area we also have and
continue to have a very high housing
need it's not just about meeting our
five-year housing land supply it's about
providing homes for the people that
desperately need them so regardless of
whether or not we try to plan for these
houses on our own or collectively with
the other part of my authorities we are
going to have to meet that housing need
somewhere somehow within our district we
feel that the best way to do that is
strategically across a wider area with
the support of the government and their
backing behind us to help to make sure
that as we do
plan for those large sites they are
getting the infrastructure in the
funding that's needed to help them
become great great places boost our
economy and put greater extras on the
map that's a really important and
special place to live and that supports
its own population with a bit of
economic base as well
Thank You Michelle are there any other
questions from counselors Alison you put
your hands up uni you know okay and I
have two things or two questions firstly
there's an eight week period suggested
for this consultation what is the basis
for selecting eight weeks is it
appropriate and given the success of the
previous online consultation what were
the lessons learned from that that are
being applied to this consultation the
second thing I'd like to raise with
members is we're talking here about the
policies to be applied not the actual
definitive those are going to be here
there or anywhere else it is the
policies that should be applied should
any developments take place so that'll
be the basis of the document that comes
forward
Michelle can I begin to the question
about the timescales please yes no
problem so a statutory consultation
period is six weeks the guest team have
proposed an eight weeks consultation
period so to extend that obviously by a
couple of weeks
our current consultation was on the
local plan that Cambridge agreed was
originally proposed for eight weeks and
it's it's like setting it statutorily we
are only required to do do six weeks so
the eight weeks just provides a little
bit of extra time for people and
obviously we have to take into account
the overall plan program and that if we
have extra long consultation periods and
that affects overall plan delivery in
the longer term if members want to
suggest a longer consultation period
then it's something that can go to the
guest team but I think given current
circumstances and and at the moment
social
they measure see in it well you know it
seems to be relaxing slightly we should
probably be able to be doing some sort
of hybrid consultation at least whether
it's largely online but we may be able
to do some socially different
face-to-face engagement if it's if it's
safe for us to do so we wouldn't have
obviously normally extended our local
plan consultation period that was
originally planned for eight weeks that
extended to twelve at the beginning of
lockdown and then in line with
government guidance and changes we
extended that and a further four weeks
to 16 weeks so it was a long program and
but again typically I just make the
point that the majority of responses
came in within the last week of
consultation and it just goes showed
that no matter how short or long your
consultation period people will wait
till the end of the consultation period
to put their comments in so I think my
advice is that stick with the eight
weeks for now so that we don't affect
overall planned program delivery and but
we can revisit that if hope in 19 or any
other circumstances suggests that we
need to extend it further
thank you that are the only other
questions from committee members I have
the one counted or wish to come back are
you making a different point yes a
second ago I'm pretty sure I thought I
heard you say that the consultation
relaxed policies whereas my
understanding it also relates to
specific sites and is key
yes in conclusion with the local plan
that does relate to policies this is the
greater area strategic plan relates to
sites it appears to be doubling down on
the all-around attack that councillor
Hawking noted that has been undertaken
on new nabbit so that's why it is
important that we understand that yes
this is sites and numbers the things
that we should have had within our own
jurisdiction as well and not be part of
a wider group that waters down our
ability to do anything about it
thank you can I just clarify them the
document is the draft policies and site
options consultation but it's seeking
people who wish to sell their land for
development to come forward it's talking
then about the policies to be applied
should any developments be agreed or
take place and go into the overall plan
so moving on from there
can I ask if there are no more questions
I have a further question try counselor
doors I've just asked you a question
as sorry Mike can you use your blue hand
but happy to come in well I would use my
blue hand if I could find it along of
two things can I just the first one was
kinds of doors to say exactly what I was
gonna say anyway the second point is on
the on the funding issue one of the
questions one of the recommendations is
that we recommend 30,000 being taken out
of reserves to go to support this the
glass team you've been in the situation
that Tim bridges are in at the moment
do we really feel it is appropriate to
take 30,000 paying more out of all
reserves when we're already struggling
are doing I don't think so and therefore
that is the second point I will vote
against thank you are there any other
questions from committee members
in which case I shall move on and invite
the portfolio Liz who are there if they
wish to make any comments or learning
portfolio holders that wish to make a
comment I'm not receiving any any
requests here we go thank you okay
councillor Taylor Thank You chair sorry
I was struggling to find my blue hand on
and just to to clarify with regard to
the policies in site options
consultation report we are looking at a
number of specific sites here there's a
two hundred and two page document
covering covering all of all of the
sites across all four authorities so the
total that we are looking at fourteen
Bridge currently in in gasp is five
thousand two hundred and fifty on a
spread of sites with the majority it
must be said actually in southwest
Exeter but some in Newton a versa as
well I thought I should clarify that at
that point that is what we're going out
to consultation for and yes I'm certain
that there's going to be some robust
responses but it's as Michelle did it
has said to us its houses also for
people who need them not just want them
it's a nice place to come and live but
there are a lot of people here who are
in need of a home needs of an affordable
home or a social rent home all of those
houses need to need to need to be built
as a government number which tells us
what we should be building and as I said
in my report at the beginning guess does
not give us any more houses than we
would have if we were to stand alone but
we have the benefit of appealing to all
of those agencies who can help us build
to bring forward infrastructure not just
with development but also in front of
developments in some cases - thank you
very much thank you any other holders
wish to make a comment
hold on let me sleep I've got councilman
Gregor I think council hook was before
me actually chair you're no you're first
on the list okay in terms of my
particular view I think I think it's
quite important to remember that we do
have as councils as local authorities a
duty to cooperate wherever possible and
the reason for that is to maximize the
the returns from from investments that
we are making as councils in these kind
of programs and developments but I think
it's also important to kind of also
focus on on where we're just about to
receive a report in this year on the
poverty aspect and one of the key
elements of that poverty aspect is the
average house price is ten times the
salary the average salary of a worker in
in teamriche that you've more than that
thing but it's it it's over ten ten time
to develop housing across the district
in in terms of and we are only
developing the number of houses that we
would normally gas consular Taylor has
pointed out we need social and
affordable housing as part of that so
they're local residents people born and
brought it brought up here kind of I'm
sorry council me you're backing in and
backing out as I literally had a note on
my screen that my internet is unstable
so I'll stop here thank you okay thank
you
council thank you
yeah I just wanted to spin it out in
simple language and you know it's easy
to make a speech saying you can have
that's had enough in the appeal to a
large section of the population possibly
we don't know but the simple fact is
whether or not we're part of guess
government is demanding we build houses
the moment of 760 ounces per year we
don't have a choice in that we have to
do it what this gal has felt out is that
team bridge and this particular
environment
until situation and constraints whatever
they might be topography etc I
recognized within the guess butene so
the chances are possibly that as a
result of that team bridge doesn't have
to take the full 760 that some of them
can be built elsewhere now faced with
those set of facts why would you not
choose to be part of gasp given as well
the fact that we're going to get a lot
of help with any infrastructure with
protecting environment etc etc I can't
understand why you wouldn't want to go
for that spelled out nice and clearly
like that that is the simple choice that
we have here now okay
Thank You Jackie right
got any other pages that would like to
make a comment
in that case are there any of our guests
from the guest team who would like to
make a comment to this thing
no right enough I can move you all on to
page 13 which that the item agenda item
9 which is the report and the
recommendations we need to go through
this and take a vote on the eight
recommendations that this report
contains I am proposing that items 1 2 3
4 and 7 are taken together they are the
approval of the policies can I have a
second a proposer and a seconder for
that so a motion please
I have I have a proposer counselor books
just disappeared um counselor Roloson
are you proposing this week separation
is one 2010 with no together chairman
okay and I have a seconder who is
counselor Goodwin battery yeah in that
case can we go please to a recorded vote
and the vote will be to accept the
recommendation for item 1 2 3 4 & 7
because if you're in favor of accepting
them you say for if you're opposed to
them you go against and obviously you
should stay in your stain
thank you so can we go to the vote
please recorded vote aye I'll do roll
call now I just like to play on the
cancer patch deep during the meeting but
obviously quite near the end of the
debate okay so thank you so we're we're
13 for recommendations 1 2 3 4 & 7 great
so councillor Austin thanks for Austin
and you need to take off your microphone
off mute new cancer Austin in case
someone you know me here and not see
Thank You councillor David Cox in favor
councillor few cogz councillor Doyle's
against councillor Eden or councillor
Foden all counselor Linda Goodman
rubbery for councillor haze Oh
councillor Hawking cousin Hawking sorry
I didn't hear that
I stood against thank you sorry
councilor Jenks oh thanks Anna Morgan Oh
counsel him alone against counselor
Nutley or counselor Nuttall can't park a
car can't let Robert Paul counselor John
pehle wreck counselor
Linda pepper Rick for counsel Steven
purser for counselor Dave Wallace turn
Oh that'll appeal thorn yeah
counselor double oven
when you ready can we have the result of
the coffee's
you
you
you
I had 19 for free against and counselor
hats not voting
thank you very much in that case those
five items are who passed up to the
executive recommendations right let's
move to item five this is the delegated
authority to the leader in commentate
middle portfolio holder and chief
executive degree changes to the above
documents arising from decisions by
other guests or authorities before they
are published for consultation the one I
would like to make one amendment to this
it shouldn't be on the basis of what the
officer has told us that this should be
minor changes so the agreement should
beef that the delegated authority to the
relief he during consultation or
portfolio than he executive to three
minor changes to the above documents
arising from decisions by other guests
or authorities for their public for
consultations can I have a propose that
we have debt a Dobler amendment weasel
I'd like to propose that please thank
you to have a seconder for that I'll
second that
thank you in each case let me go
straight to the vote for that amended
version can I just ask a question under
I agree with portfolio holder the leader
and the managing director but shouldn't
the officer be involved there somewhere
I think the delegation of the well the
officers are involved this is a
political decision
No so it's the political bodies involved
so the officers representing bartender
chief executive the councillors by the
leader on the portfolio holders so
I think this it's up for those people to
be that delegate within their own deep
arms within their own team cancer James
he's waving furiously thank you thank
you chair I do I do agree with with with
that amendment but I was going to make
an amendment of my own and my amendment
would delegate authority to the leader
in consultation Holder leader of the
Opposition and miner and managing
director to agree changes to the above
documents arising from decisions by the
other guest authorities before they are
published for consultation and to email
all members within 24 hours of those
changes or second now we have two men if
you're ok with with those changes I
think they're reasonable amendments as
long as the word mine is in there as
well and why the consultation I'm always
in favor of if there is the will of the
committee then that is the amendment we
will put forward to a vote can I just
check the amendment that we're going to
put to the vote that cuts the proper
course agreed counselor Jenks it's a to
add the word minor to changes add the in
consultation with the leader of the
Opposition and email members within 24
hours we won't say that's counselor
dates proposed by David Cox
so David sorry thank you
Oh y'all okay in that case can we go to
please a recorded vote for that amended
version fees
okay before we move on Alison Eden's
just raised a question yeah I just said
I just think it what's the criteria for
minor because what's what's major - one
person is minor to another
well I think sorry yeah let Michelle
lost Kim's put her hand up so perhaps
she could be to use the term minors that
she would be happy to explain that would
be lovely thank you thank you thank you
generally when we talk about minor we're
talking about points of clarification
typographical errors etc it would be
nothing that went to the heart of the
plan so there wouldn't be anything that
had any sort of change to the intention
of any policy wording or sight proposal
in this context because I can see a
situation where lots of people start
kind of you know pinging and where it
becomes a you said I said this is me at
minder this is may you I don't agree
with you but I think the spirit of
what's intended is clear I think the
control is described is adequate
editorial changes because they don't get
the content or the strategy will you be
happy with that term Michelle yeah I'd
be happy with that term editorial
changes the cooks dad okay I think
everybody's happy with that okay Alan's
okay I'll do the roll call councillor
Austin
for councillor David cogs cancer the
doors hi
I did a try and ask a question great
race raised a blue hand I wanted for the
total charity for the amendment to be
read out clear what the amendment is now
would you care to really member dad
please Sarah yeah I know they say
delegated authority to the leader in
consultation with the portfolio holder
leader of the Opposition and chief
executive to agree minor editorial
changes to the above documents arising
from decisions by other guest
authorities before they are published
for consultation and emailed to members
within 24 hours
there is the amendment cancer doors
that's what you're voting on counselor
Eden Oh counselor Soudan or plant alert
give them back rubbery pool councillor
haze Oh counselor Mike Hawking okay
councillor Jenks or counselor Morgan Oh
counselor Malone sorry I'm sorry odd
form that's alert John Nutley or not all
Hey
all pull Sara
papapaa canceler pert for counselor John
pehle Rick Linda the wreck tour that's
mistreatment purser for that's there
Dave Wallace turn Oh counselor build
thorn or counselor double oven or you
can let us have the count as soon as you
have it please
like that's 22 for when agates and can't
slip patch didn't vote on that one again
okay now move to item 2 recommendation
number 6 which is to approve a further
call for sites process to be held
alongside the consultation on the guest
graph policies and site options document
we have a proposal for that
recommendation please
can I propose that that amendment is
accepted you have a second different
motion
you
I have a signal from John Patrick that
to counsel Patrick that he is happy to
stick in that motion
can we therefore move to vote on item
six please
okay okay this comes in your report
cancel it Austin it's lost in for
councillor David coughs oh it gives us
the chance to change sites
Thank You cots doors against consulate
Eden Chancellor Bowden Oh Chancellor
Linda give me a break fool
councillor Hayes Oh
councillor Hawking okay counselor James
Malone against cancelling Utne or
so John Patrick Patrick Patrick okay
perik's frozen oh yeah cancer John
Patrick yes Patrick
pencil dick John Henry can you hear me
so I think he's frozen I think I'm
lenders just dropped out as well
all right okay let me do for I'll come
back to join you in a minute
counselor purser Paul cancer Ralston Oh
counselor thorn yeah counselor John
Patrick Sarah do you want me to get him
to come to this computer
uh it might be yes especially as these
seconded the motion is my really nice
though so it like yeah
speeding like a gazelle Thank You
counselor but oven cool okay just being
healthy countess is you can
you
right twenty four or three ago it's
canceled a patch not voting that is
approved again move now to item 8 which
is the approval for the expenditure to
create or increase the guest team up to
eight people are there any questions
about this item
there are no councillor questions I have
Andrew a counselor and um again I'm
sorry andrew has a portfolio that will
move straight to the vet on this sorry I
have Richard doors coming up as well
cancer doors hi sorry could you explain
in more detail what this constitutes
please Thank You Nick can I refer it
back to the portal you hold it James -
Taylor do you want to answer that
question or what would you prefer
Michelle to come forward and answer
Thank You chair I I'd certainly I'd be
happy for for Michelle to answer in more
detail on this the the expenditure is I
set out in appendix F on the paperwork
on the documents attached to the agenda
item appendix F page 29 to 31 and so
perhaps Michelle perhaps another member
of the guests team if if that's
appropriate to just take us through and
take in a bit more detail on the on the
costings please Thank You Michelle would
you care to respond yes I am I have to
respond on this one so hopefully it's
clearly set out from the report but
basically we've gone from a situation
with the interception of the guess team
where it was agreed to the each
Authority would put two officers from
their authority into the guest team and
we also have resource from Democrats
Council as well from the start the guest
resources weren't contributed equally
between all of the partner authorities
due to various other commitments and
staffing issues the different
authorities had and so we've always been
in a situation really from the start
where the contribution of resources has
never been equitable into into the guest
team and the start we we had eight and a
half full-time equivalents within the
guest team
and those have dwindled over the last
few years so that were in a situation at
the moment where we only have 5.2 FTEs
and the team and it's clear from the
analysis that we've done and obviously
the work that we're trying to do at the
moment that this just isn't sufficient
resource in order to complete the
project and and meet the timescales as
well that we've been looking at so this
has been discussed amongst the project
advisory group for the guests and then
it's been taken through the leadership
group as well and it has been agreed in
principle to go to each of the
respective councils and asked for that
resourcing to be brought up to an
equitable level and for it to be brought
up to eight full-time equivalents as
well so that is requesting for an
additional resource from us however so
between April 17 and April 20 2010 which
were putting in quite a significant
amount of resource with one senior
processor and then we had the team
leader in their assignments only as well
so prior to April our annual
contribution was actually significantly
more than we're currently asking for at
the moment at 62,000 so even with asking
for this additional contribution now
they're still a saving of around 45,000
pounds compared to what we were paying
at the beginning of the year towards the
guest team and I think the key thing is
that it's agreement that those resources
the contributing extra between the four
local planning authorities and that it's
clear that individual authorities can't
make unilateral decisions just to remove
staff from the guest team and then
compromise delivery of the project
overall so this is really asking you
know for a commitment to delivering the
project and to resourcing it fairly and
properly thank you very sure you come
back with a further question answer
doors yes my my question and my
understanding is a director
lemon tea company is that your few dish
iary duties are that you need to be able
to meet your debts as they fall jus now
can the committee be reassured the team
bridge District Council has the
resources and funds to undertake this
obligation and this commitment when
currently my understanding is the
council's on the edge of a financial
precipice and they shouldn't be making
commitments and obligations it clearly
has no ability to meet if I can answer
that the council if it hasn't the
resources to meet its obligations has to
issue the 1 1 4 notice no such notice
has been issued there's no such notice
in the course separation and therefore
the quit they cancel by definition has
the resources to meet the obligations
that's being asked to meet can be there
for a move on to the vote on item 8
please sorry it's sorry to come back and
up could I could I just know that the
statement you made there chair that that
be minuted in in detail they did exactly
verbatim passage yes it is a recorded
meeting as you know it's in the public
domain
I know in the minutes of the meeting if
think I'm happy that it goes into the
minutes of the meeting can we move
therefore to the vote please this is
against recommendation number 8 that the
guest is brought up to eight full-time
equivalents and the cost of doing so is
equitably shared between the four
members of guests please sorry I haven't
heard proposed kind of a proposer that
we accept number eight please
recommendation eight is anybody waving
at me yeah that chair thank you I've
also got Dave Rollerson councillor
olesen well you say
I'll be prepared to Second Council thank
you very much
we have a we have a proposal in the
second that they're for coming move to
the recorded vote please
okay counselor cancel it Austin Oh for
absolutely David Cox for canceler Hugh
Cox
oh that's the doors against cancel it
Eden Oh counselor Foden can still give
them back Bradbury for counselor Hayes
oh that's love hockey
okay thanks love James or cancel Morgan
oh that's them alone against that slur
nutley or cancel Nuttall hey that's
alert form against cancer Parker can
cancel it hurt door cancel it John
plethoric cancer Linda pedak Oh
counselor purser poor cancer Ralston oh
that's Luthor yeah that's a liberal oven
[Music]
then the others have the account to
Sue's you all right I have 19 for four
games and Castle attacks thank you
right
can we therefore move on to item 10 on
the agenda which is the joint statement
of community involvement
come on I therefore invite council Gary
Taylor to introduce the item and I think
he'll then pass to Michel ask him to any
further points excuse excuse me care yes
just just to go back to one of the
points that we start counseling McGregor
I'm sorry you don't remember the
committee can we therefore ask Gary
Taylor to come forward and present
please certainly mr. chair members thank
you once again
item 10 on your agenda refers to the
Greater extra teaching plan joint
statement of community involvement or
joint SCR for short this joint SC I sets
out the proposed approach to public
consultation on the guest as it
progresses through its statutory plan
making stages towards adoption a
statement of community involvement is
produced by a local authority to form
members of the public how they can
become involved in statutory planning
matters how they will be consulted and
how long the various consultation
periods will remain open as we have
heard earlier from Michelle only
yesterday the longest consultation
period I believe Cambridge has ever
conducted finally closed after our local
plan part one remained open for a twice
extended 16 weeks due to the coab in 19
lockdown while it is very much hope that
lockdown will not return the threat
remains which has resulted in the guest
s CI consultation period being increased
from six weeks to eight weeks this
increase will allow more time to prepare
thoughtful and wollen evidence comments
and will help organizations
such as parish or town councils who need
to take comments through a committee
structure to properly respond the
reference in the wording to some
consultation methods taking place where
possible in adversity comest enables
greater flexibility to progress the plan
during the uncertain period of coded 19
in some events such as face to face
public exhibitions if some events can't
take place meaningful engagement will
still be ensured using alternative
methods such as social media and online
exhibitions this flexible approach is
supported by government guidelines the
urge local authorities such as ours to
progress plan making during the corona
virus pandemic and has provided
invaluable in our local plan part 1
consultation during July and August to
2020 support for the guests twitter
joint SC i will also be sought from the
relevant decision-making bodies and each
of the other greater aces of local
authority planning planning local
planning authorities should any one of
the greater Exeter local planning
authorities suggest change to the joint
SC I there will need to be a meeting of
the council leaders in consultation with
portfolio holders and chief executives
are equivalent to agree a consolidated
version of the document mr. chairman
members I commend the report to you for
your positive recommendation that the
executive committee approves the content
of the document and a job and adopts the
joint SC is set out a and B on pages on
page 33 and I hand over now to to show
muscum who I will give him a few more
details on this item
Thank You councillor Taylor and I don't
really have much more to add on it like
I said earlier I think the report is
fairly self-explanatory on the FCI we
require an SCR I it's a statutory
requirement when we consult on plans we
have one of our own 14 bridge which was
adopted last year and so yes earlier yes
last year sorry um and and that's what
we used to consult on the local plan
obviously this one because it's
before different local planning
authorities we need have consistency in
how we're setting up in sports or
engaging with the public and so this
seminal community involvement was a
draft one was consulted on in 2017
alongside the issues consultation on
their guests comments were received
they've been taken into account and
incorporated into this version of the
statement of community involvement and
it also reflects the recent government
ident simulation to consultation during
the coab it 19 restrictions as well yeah
I'm happy to take any questions thank
you Genisys your own questions for us I
have two people raising hands cancer
Ellison sorry char didn't know that my
blue hand was still up from previous
time okay chance the drinks yeah I would
just like to to recommendation be to
reflects my previous amendment so I
would like it read gives delegated
authority to the leader in consultation
with the portfolio holder leader of the
opposition and managing director to
agree minor editorial changes and
emailing all members within 24 hours of
these changes to the joint SC I and then
as the rest reads thank you very have a
second over that proposed amendment I'd
like to second that we have proposed on
a seconder before we move to a vote on
your questions of Cox
y'all just gonna sect and the previous
thing that's already done
okay client counter doors just picking
up on the comments from from Michelle I
just like reassurance given that the
bodies that I represent the patent of
parish councils the residents
Association and the concerns expressed
by some Devin that the consultation is
without doubt covering our legal
requirements in terms of yes the BSC I
as it Kristen includes all of our legal
requirements in terms of how we're going
to consult and as long as we accord with
those then that will address all of our
statutory requirements if there are any
specific issues or ideas that you have
then I'm sure the guess team would be
more than happy to have a listen 30 days
and take those into account so if you
could direct any of those to the guest
team I can give you their contact
details are on their website then that
would be great
thank you for that are any other
questions from a young committee I have
no other questions being raised in
earlier 14 fights any portfolio holding
counsel McGregor you wanted to make the
point earlier you joinder coming in
there
Thank You chair it was just to go back
to one of the amendments that's been
voted on the one where minor changes can
be approved by the leader there in
consultation with a leader in the
opposition and the chief exec but quite
like that just to be clarified we don't
have a chief exec and we have a managing
director and there are historical
reasons for that so yes to make sure
that that is correctly recorded as
managing director not chief exec on the
amendment fine that's a point well made
thank you any other port authority
holders would like to make a comment
about this
you
you
I have nobody coming it forward
page 33 recommend ot is amended in the
same way that the previous amendment was
made and I'd suggest that we mirror the
comments that were from the previous
amendments which I think counter james
employed in further of his proposal that
those same amendments reply into this
paragraph on that basis
Sara can you read out the the changes
that would employ for you okay it's B
its delegated authority to the leader in
consultation with the portfolio holder
leader of the Opposition and Managing
Director to agree changes to the joint
agree my sorry Mike do you want agree
mine toriel changes again sigh okay okay
I'll start again so everyone's clear
gives delegated authority to the leader
in consultation with the portfolio
holder leader of the Opposition and
Managing Director to agree minor
editorial changes to the joint SC I
arising from the decision by the other
guests local planning authorities and to
circulate to email to all members within
24 hours and to approve it as a local
development document noting that it will
apply jointly to e stubbornly district
extra City mid Devon district and team
bridge district councils thank you
in that case can we please move to the
vote on this can we go through the roll
call please Sarah Katz Austin Austin for
councilors David Cox or casler Huw Cox
cancel the doors against counselor Eden
or counselor Foden all Natalie Goodman
Bradbury fool can't let haze or Hawking
yeah for us we got to go through this
pursue counselor Jenks or cancel Morgan
or counseling Malone thanks counselor
nutley or counselor Nuttall hey
counselor all who enter the park on
cancer patch for plant or counsel John
plethoric Linda Patrick the meeting
counselor parecer or counselor Rolleston
or counselor thorn yeah okay I'll just
check the tables
sorry I didn't call out counselor
Bullivant for typology
21 for 2 against and limits now left the
meeting so I see ok thank you very much
indeed for that moving on there towards
me 11 in the agenda can I thank by the
way before we move on to item 11 the
people from s bouquet thank you for
listening Gordon instructions or wish to
go now that's absolutely fine thank you
right if you move on to item 11 the
impact of Corbett 19 on council services
this document was circulated as a
separate document within the units but
can I call upon councillor hook Gordon
book to present and introduce Tony
Mansell who take us through the
paperwork thank you
doesn't appear we have counsel hook with
us is your show filled with yes I am
here and looking forward to contributing
sat quietly by which is difficult for me
in the last hour or so but so I didn't
think it was my place to intervene and
some of the issues that were raised I'd
like to introduce this this paper and
this particular item on the agenda to
talk essentially on the generalities of
the recommendations and it would be for
members to look perhaps in more detail
following Toni's presentation of some of
the detail off the of the package before
us some members will remember they might
even have read the letter that I sent
out last week to all members where not
knowing that this particular opportunity
was coming forward at this particular
time I not only took the opportunity of
thanking members and officers for the
enormous amount of proactive and
positive work that has been carried out
during this appalling lockdown period
that we're all enduring but also to to
encourage if that if that's the right
word at this time as much as possible
cross chamber cooperation and working
for the for the common good of all our
respective communities and that is
essentially what is behind my comments
this morning and in looking at the
recommendations that are there because
we're asking for different working
groups to the established under under
number two whether that's two three or
four depends on comments that might be
made later in the morning but
essentially this is a great opportunity
to help in our communities across the
board to weigh up the opinion of
residents and to take on board
recommendations of recommend of
residents regarding the work of the
council under this Kovach 19 period it
is a unique opportunity and this is a
unique period of time
we're living through and I used that off
to used word it with the true meaning of
that word we face as a district as a
country as a world economic catastrophe
individuals families businesses are
facing financial ruin we have
unemployment soaring we have or we
appear to be for the moment at least
living through a period of social
dislocation with an increased disregard
for law and order and basic social
behavior of anything like a reasonable
standard we are living through of course
a health risk higher than anything any
of us have known in our lifetimes and I
say there all seriousness and sadness
that I believe that while the first
phase appears to eased we continue to
face an enormous risk from a recurrence
of Kovach 19 and associated at the depan
demyx I hate to say this but I don't
believe the worst is over I think we are
in as I say a unique and uniquely
difficult situation added to which we
have the possibility of a No Deal brexit
and overriding all of that climate
change this is a period of enormous
enormous problem for the nation and for
us all as individuals for our friends
our neighbors our communities and I am
appealing across the chamber for us to
work together wherever we possibly can
on this this this situation we have a
chance here through Toni's report
working with me on Blaney to actually do
something positive and proactive within
our communities and I catch those words
in in the reflection of and
and the acceptance of the fact that many
of you are already heavily engaged in
your communities doing fantastic work
and I thank you unreservedly for their
I'm sorry to repeat that but it is worth
repeating
I believe this isn't the time for
unnecessary bickering it's not a time
for unnecessary disagreements it isn't
the time for nitpicking and silly silly
silly interventions I do do implore
everyone in this chamber to coalesce
around this opportunity and commit
themselves to often offering yourself to
take part in these working groups that
are being proposed as I say unique
problems but unique opportunities I
dispute the Prime Minister's words of
build build build our way out of the
problem the three B's I have three other
bees not the Boris Johnson bees but the
golden hook bees those words should be
billed back better
we have an opportunity to review our
policies and our ambitions I want to see
a green environmental sustainable future
and this is the opportunity a unique as
I say opportunity in the history of tea
bridge in the history of the world let's
grasp that by cooperating working
together thinking about our communities
and the welfare of people who are
suffering about to suffer enormous
deprivation and of course all the time
living with this this huge health risk I
hope very much that we can combined with
recovery taking it forward in a positive
way and I leave Tony to add some flesh
to my appeal and my generalities I'm
happy to answer any questions in the
fullness of time chairman and make
further comment but I hope I've got my
message across that is this is too
serious a time
but flippancy then killer counsel who go
on to call that anyone's order but I did
ask if it's only is there or the igneel
if they would like to know speak in
rather more detail about erm our
recovery program and structure of
productivity within the context of the
proposals and the recommendations okay
Tony are you going to everybody hear me
okay yeah thank you so the report that I
provided is a review of the council's
response to the impact of Tobin 19 and
outlines our approach to recovery
we have two recommendations firstly that
members notice lost accounts was
response to kind of iris code
mid-nineteen pandemic to date and also
that two working groups are established
by overview and scrutiny committee to
firstly assess the impact of toby 19 on
communities in rural urban and coastal
areas calling witnesses from each and
then there to review the council
strategy in light of Tobit 19 determine
whether the plans still hold true but
pre-planned she'd been able now it is a
long report and i want obviously in
detail all the others of it but by way
of background the council has a football
practice pandemic by continuing to
deliver core services whilst also
realigning staff and resources to
respond to the emerging needs of the
community and government initiatives the
report outlines of preparation and
little response how we respond this
committee need and business need the
services that we've been able to
maintain apathetic and those services
which have had to be suspended or
restricted and also our communications
approach and the financial position of
the council as I'm sure you're aware
moving in response to recovery all the
evidence during this pandemic points to
an extended response babies with the
potential for further spikes and
infections this is reflected regionally
in the approach taken by the recovery
coordination group the rcg and
nationally in terms of the stages and
conditional plans relaxed restrictions
on movement contacts a walking peered
increasingly likely regardless of the
duration is that a council will emerge
into a very different economic landscape
and will have different impacts on the
community we serve in view of this it's
important we take a strategic approach
to recovery to ensure that we learn from
response expand new challenges that we
face and emerge as an organization that
fit the purpose and financially
sustainable
we've provided a governance structure
and key objectives for recovery
the council also continues to play a
leading role alongside partners in
responding to the short medium and long
term impacts that can pandemic an
engagement with our community should be
at the forefront of our recovery efforts
we must engage with and listen to the
communities that we serve and continue
to do so
understanding that the full extent of
the economic shock caused by could in
nineteen is not yet been realized with
reference to that statement we're
proposing as I've touched on to
establish to task and finish group the
first one is to understand the impact of
po bid 19 on rural coastal and urban
communities within teen bridge and to
make recommendations to open scrutiny on
four areas firstly what actions and
priorities the cattle to take was I
think in a review of the council
strategy and referring to support team
bridge communities in their recovery
from the impact to lockdown period
identify short medium and long term
timescales the identified actions and
priorities an overview of any potential
financial and resource implications of
the identified actions and priorities
and any changes required to the terms of
reference to the coab in nineteen
council strategy review group we've
proposed that these are group on the
community impact element of coated
report with final recommendations to
over the in scrutiny committee by the
end of January 2021 it will be provided
with a result city Neal Blaney who is
the head commercial services and
strategic lead for recovery myself as
the project leader recovery support from
our community safety project manager our
policy officer on community projects
officer our PA two directors for admit
appalled and that we're cool with that
group cause rural parish representatives
community and voluntary sector groups
local business representatives and
constituents and resident groups the
second group that we're proposing is
established is to review the council
strategy 2020 to 2030 objective imagined
after the issues arising from lockdown G
to covered 19 and report and a report of
the coab in nineteen community impact
task and finish group and to make
recommendations to overview in scrutiny
on four areas which programs objectives
and actions still remain deliverable
which programs objectives and actions
are considered undeliverable and why any
additional objectives and actions that
should form part of the council's a
recovery plan and the MOU review of any
potential financial results implications
and the identify factions and priorities
now it's proposed that the talk and
theater group with my recommendation is
to sneak by the end of May 20 21 it will
be given resources including myself and
Emil action on climate through David
Eaton and the project leads for each of
the t10 project so as I said David eaten
a roof over our heads which we led by
Grande Davy clean team led by Chris
brains going to town Neil Blaney a great
places to work and live a live which is
or eastman best properity
was just b4c moving up again bogus
plates out and about an active James
pede strong communities Becca Hewitt and
vital viable counsel Amanda Pujol so
working closely with all of those t10
project leads to review the viability of
the council strategy also you'll be
provided with resource in terms of
myself and Neil Blaney and Rebecca here
as committee Safety Partnership manager
Eve Bates as policy officer and an halt
providing admin support so I'd like to
post any questions on the content of the
report which is the review of the
council response thus far the impact of
Kovach 19 all the recommendations which
resulted to the establishment of the
dysley task and finish group thank you
thank you are there any questions for
people raising their hands at the moment
starting off Chris Jones thank you Tony
and and Gordon and I just want to come
if you could confirm just a couple of
things and if I could maybe suggest a
couple of things and with the the
coastal urban and rural area can you
confirm that they will be three separate
groups and if they are three separate
groups could the rural group maybe
combine themselves with revitalizing the
rural campaign to a better resources and
maybe hit two birds with one stone and
as for the second group as well it would
probably make sense to do it with a
letter asking finish group that will be
discussed as well but the rewards income
generation ideas as well yeah if you
just confirm that the for the first
three groups will be three separate
groups and that there won't be a
political split in those groups please
can I respond to that Phil
[Music]
they Lea structure we learn the three
separate make a choice on within ons as
I don't have any issues about having a
separate group wouldn't you want to add
to that I'm not sure if everybody
everybody got that you froze in the
middle of that Phil and I'm not sure I
picked it all up but let me respond as I
am able and if if I don't clarify
Chrissy's points then please come back
at me Chris and say I didn't know so
that I'm and I didn't hear what you were
saying I'm afraid so but I'll try and
respond I think it's very good I think
the suggest is very good Chris that this
should be a rural economic
revitalization as much as any other and
and certainly if that group can pick up
on that that would be good and that's
the positive contribution I am I'm
hopeful that they'll be enough
volunteers to produce at least six
members for each of the three working
groups rural urban and coastal if that
isn't the case if there aren't
sufficient volunteers and one would hope
there would be but if there aren't
sufficient then I hope they would
certainly be sufficient for two and
therefore there could be Kabam a
combination and an overlap but ideally
in my book there would be three covering
the three distinct areas in that context
I'm very happy totally happy to accept
that there won't be political
proportionality on those committees
because as I've said this I believe that
the problems we are facing are too big
for for unnecessary political
point-scoring and this is not one of
those cases at all let's have volunteers
doing the work doing the concentration
in the communities irrespective of their
political label does that answer the
point you were making or on whether
one's I missed that's good thank you
was that a rock film with the
yeah I mean we had this discussion about
making it non-political and I'm totally
endorsing that it isn't going to be
possible to maintain the normal 3 to 1
ratio that's fine with me as I said it
this is a test gonna finish group of ons
so it'll be the ons committee that sets
the form and structure provided it
delivers against the overall
requirements laid down or against the
ret terms of reference then I'm happy to
accept the recommendation that
councillor Jenks has made I'm sorry Phil
I'm very very keen to get on with this
because it is critically important work
I think set out by tony was consultation
in September analysis in October and
report back to ons in November if we can
bring that forward in any way by
starting the consultation process sooner
I would be in favor of that
yeah with with the virtual nature of our
meetings these days I don't see that
that's impossible
and it would be good if we could at
least set the whole thing up now
therefore we hit the holiday period of
August
I agree but we'll talk about that in the
in the committee council pocket con you
had a question
and yes firstly I'd like to say thank
you Tony for the reports and I agree
with Gordon now is now is the time that
we need to collaborate for the good of
the district but it's also that we
celebrate the things that worked well
and but examining those that were more
tricky and perhaps where we need to make
improvements and we talked a lot about
recovery in this report and I'm
concerned that if we do see a second
spike very early on in the autumn and
that we're able to respond really
quickly and that we've learned the
lessons from the lockdown and that we
can implement improvements and how that
is going to be addressed from now on so
that we're ready that we're really
really prepared for next time so we
don't make the same mistakes and that we
improve if we need to and I think
Gordon's eye
bringing it forward is very useful
actually Thank You counselor doors you
have a question hi yes I'd agree with
much of what Gordon said I mean the
challenges the district the country
a seismic I think I've said the same to
all councilors and started the pandemic
and was accused of shrill hyperbole but
we're all there now everything has just
changed and we just whistled through
gasp this will go down as an age of
idiocy but I would definitely back any
year zero approach and we all pulled
together on and for once working the
very best interests of the residents so
I for one will be pulling together my
parish councils my residents group my
electorate and imploring the District
Council to act in their interests thank
you very carefully he would say that we
all work on respect of all of our
electorate doesn't matter what they are
where they are we will work on benefit
to the area there on the a V Hall um
there are no hands I make a number of
points the proposal is that we have two
working groups that we can subdivide as
we wish bite circulated members last
week with an email asking you each to
nominate whether you wish to serve
within one or the other I had about 20
members respond which puts about fifteen
people in one group and about nine in
the other some people gone from both
groups must pass to one I'd encourage
those who haven't yet responded so to do
and from that will create the groups and
I agree with Gordon's request that we
accelerate the program and in that
regard there are two things that I'd
like to draw out within the
recommendations firstly the struck
the document talks of a total of six
members per group and the groups are
sequential so one group goes through
produces its report which then feeds
into the second group I'm not easy with
that I think both groups should be set
up at the star both should start working
admittedly the productive work that one
group will happen when the results from
the first group available but there is
other work that can be done in parallel
and ought to be done in parallel the
second thing I agree with Gordon that
this should be non politically biased in
any way and therefore I believe any
council so that has a wish to be
involved should be involved and
therefore restricting the membership of
each group to the power of six I don't
think he's right I think if a councillor
has an interest it is it there right if
not duty to getting bold with the group
that they want to be involved with so
I'm not regard subject to your your
important wish so I propose that we
accept the two structures and they would
for the officers have put forward rights
make amendments to the group should be
non-political yeah yes sir
sorry you win a signal so I wouldn't
take I know what amendment political I
am see I'm suggesting that the group
membership should be redefined there's a
minimum of six members and that the
group should be non politically biased
not that's the wrong turn to use but
it's independent of political party okay
and we had counseled against it that
these are these working groups that
councillor Jackson said about having if
if possible
three working groups want to cover
roller open and coastal I'm happy that
within this one group they can subdivide
so yes I agree we should never focus on
each of the three areas but it should be
within the overall group so they're all
working in parallel and feeding together
because I think there's going to be a
lot of cross-pollination between the
ideas important comments that it would
be very useful to get the group talking
about so it comes look at three
individual areas comes together to
produce the final feedback into the
report it makes to learn a mess in terms
of timescales I think we should create
the two groups straightaway we should
look at the work programs and see what
can be done in both groups straight away
and set them both running because I
agree with Gordon we need this
information but doing is eight feet we
need to be ready for us flight like
later in the earth if it happen and
there's a lot of lessons that we can
learn then we should learn and that will
be useful in preparing for its
subsequent spike so those are the two
things that I personally subject to your
approval I would suggest that we all
turn this on these two documents
can I have a I'm proposing those two
changes can I have a second Thank You
councillor Pierre and I ask the
questions are I right I think the raise
- sorry yes thank you sure I just wanted
to point out that the time scales that
we've set out are based on the resources
got available so if we're going to
change the level of work and the number
of people involved in the live
organization that's will be not enough
resource it's also mindful at the time
and workloads that currently exist
so what wants in in certain those dates
is to be realistic on what we can
achieve and that it's mindful of the
fact that we set up meetings over the
summer they're not as well attended as
in other months and we
whether it's gonna be quite the same
this year closely the summer months are
gonna be a little bit different given
overall national issues or international
issues but it's just before members
votes on this just to be very mindful
but this will be quite a lot of work to
pull it all together and not
underestimate the resource that's going
to be required to do that so happy where
we can subsea support and and help this
be delivered or it is quite a big
resource requirement Neil I totally
understand the point you make I'm not
looking at the officers in terms of I
totally understand that you'll give the
resource as it's required in the
whenever you can but I think equally
councillors working together have to
recognize that we have to work together
as councillors and if it needs us doing
the work it needs the councillors to get
off their seats and deliver what is
necessary but I don't see changing the
time scales or reprioritizing for the
committee should necessarily have any
impact on the time scales of officer
being officers being available I'm not
looking for an increase you see my
series also to do that counts of public
art and just a quick question is there
any restriction on count soliciting on
both groupings again that's a choice of
the committee I personally don't have
any issues about that any councillors in
title who attend any committee take part
of any committee from my mine okay are
there any other questions
in that case can we move to a vote on
this yep and urban areas and yeah yeah
yes okay can we therefore move to vote
on there and approving this
recommendation subject to those minutes
please
can we do a roll call Austin cancer
Austin David Cox for add a hue Cox for
the doors for Chancellor Eden oh that's
a phone or that's the Goodman Bob Rae
Oh Chancellor Hayes Oh
Tesla Hawking
that's with jokes whoa
that's the Morgan oh that's Malone oh
that's an ugly or that's Nuttall a
handler on story counselor room I didn't
hear gone it is counselor warm still I
think she may have left the meeting I
can't see me like thank you Oh counselor
patch or that's let it pour counselor
John plethoric Oh counselor Steven
purser poor that's alert Rolleston oh
that's Luthor yeah okay that was
unanimous for everyone in the meeting
just the record yeah okay okay
so there applies to both the
recommendations on yet the Corbett
document okay thank you thank you very
much for that can we move on to item 12
on the report which is the report of the
task and finish group that was looking
at council performance information can I
invite council person to present his
report Thank You chairman as this report
was was initially carried out in the
different world it was set up back in
November when basically the the concern
was that Chancellor's were receiving a
hundred plus page performance report
quarterly and to be honest it sort of
God's can't review partly because of the
quantity of it and therefore we felt
that the task and finish group should be
set up to see how we could make that
information more meaningful to
counselors I'd like to
all the councillors who actually
attended and had input into the group
I'd like very much to thank the staff
involved I don't see any of them on my
screen today so Sarah if you could pass
on my thanks to the staff who are
involved in in preparing these reports
I'd be grateful what the report is
proposing to do is just to concentrate
on the areas that we would refer to as
red and amber but I want to make the
strong point that they are a minor group
of performance indicators the bulk of
our indicators are all green and
positive and I think we mustn't lose
sight of the the good work that is being
done by Team bridge but I saw the
perhaps over looking at sort of red and
Amber's and saying the world is bad
because it isn't most of nearly all of
the report items are green which is is
really good news moving on to what
you've got in front of you
obviously the young the first items is
actually a format of what we're
proposing to do and basically it's an
exception report that just highlights
the Reds it shows the position they're
at it also gives officer information as
to what the problem is and the proposal
is that at the ONS meetings when these
come forward the portfolio holders will
be available to actually elaborate on on
what the concerns are and what's being
done to put them right and members will
be able to submit questions hopefully
three clear working days before rather
than just at the meeting the other item
areas as Appendix two is the protocol of
how that would work as an OH&S meeting
and Upendra final appendix I've been
shopping papers is something that we had
started which was them portfolio holders
coming by annually to ons to report
obviously I've seen we don't have any
on this current Aaron s meeting but I
would assume Phil we'd probably restart
that again at the next investment
meeting with a couple of portfolio
holders coming along and that's all I
really wanted to say chairman I think
the reports are all fairly
self-explanatory about how we're going
full with you there are six
recommendations there which I think are
all non-contentious or I hope they're
non contentious but I'm happy chairman
to answer any questions that members
might have thank you and thanks for an
excellent work that your group carried
out here this came about because when we
were looking at the performance the back
end of last year we recognized that a
lot of time was being spent by offices
producing part tree of firm reports
every every quarter and it wasn't really
focusing the mind of counselors on the
issues and therefore we said it the best
thing to do is separate those to get a
report which focus the minds on the
issues at the same time create a
structure where they portfolio holders
had the opportunity quarter every half
year to come before the committee to
update us on what actually was going on
within their portfolio holders we
basically picked up all of the green
issues and enable them to explain why
they were being delivered how they were
being delivered and the successes that
they have so I'd like to recommend that
the report is passed up to the executive
with a recommendation that the suggested
improvements or changes are implemented
as soon as they can be so can I have a
seconder for that motion please I have
Sarah Parker on and a Roloson other day
were you there to second it comes with
Rolla says yes chairman I'm very happy
to second bitten congratulation thank
you are there any other questions for
counselor person ok can we do we need to
go to a vote on this I think
yes you should go to local vote unless
unless of course there's unless if
you're all in agreement then then you
know if it's all happy to do it that way
I'll leave it up to you Jeff oh okay are
there any dissenting voices anybody that
doesn't wish to vote in favor of this
motion I have received known notices of
anybody wishing to dissent with this
motion and therefore can I say this
motion is passed unanimously yep
can you record it as a unanimous vote
please in favor Thank You members thank
you thank you quickly moving on there
there are two proposals for two new task
and finish group so word for word one is
about employment making employment sites
worker this one page 67 of your agenda
the second is about a specific project
which I'll come on to if you can look at
the employment sites work it's making
employment sites work we have a number
of instances and it's been a constant
theme over the last few years where we
are seeing development sites employment
sites coming forward not being developed
not coming forward or applications
coming forward and being turned down and
we are not delivering the jobs and the
sites that those jobs need to meet our
aspirations are later within or lay down
within our plans in talking with
officers we need to understand the core
reasons why and the view is to use the
abilities of the ONS to calling external
bodies people to ask the questions find
out and see if we can establish white
sites on coming forward if the sites are
approved why they're not being developed
the issues that we basically face in
terms of delivery the jobs that our
residents need and to do that proposal
is to create a task and finish group to
be the the focus to ask those questions
and my proposal here therefore is to
create a group minimum it will be
proportional to membership a political
party membership three to one but to
create a group that will look at this
invite external people to come and talk
so we can get a view and then we can
feed that observation into the executive
so they can take it into account as we
move forward so can I ask that the first
item which is making employment sites
work we have a pre-approval to create a
task and finish group to do this work
can I have it I'll propose it can I have
a second the police for that motion I'll
second there thank you are there any
questions anybody wishes to ask I have
no questions raise no hands raised in
that case can I go through 12 of those
please do you want
are there any dissenting voices anybody
who does not agree with this approach
I have nobody indicating that they wish
to dissent disagree can I therefore
assume that this is a unanimous with the
creative group yes I have no dissenting
voices in that case we'll take it as a
unanimous vote in favor thank you in
terms of creating the group I was
circulated note to each of the group
leaders and asked for a nomination for
their nominations to sit on this
committee okay the second one that comes
towards a bit different those of us that
sit on and this is delivering a shared
vision for new strategic developments
those counselors who wear two hats sit
on a town and district council or
district and County we constantly see
there's a disagreement or a lack of
understanding that is best to put it
between the roles of the different
levels of local government and its
stopping effective working between town
parish district and County we've seen
this constantly certainly over the last
five years I've seen I'm sure every
other council has seen it as well where
the Town Council's they have a view it's
not respected or not
yeah you lost signal there so you might
want to see it a little bit what you
said let me see myself all the time but
I don't know whether you know okay what
we're trying to do here is create a
framework document that it shows how
different tiers of Liberal government
can and should be working together to
deliver a common aspiration now the view
here is that we have in Newton Abbot a
wish at the town level and district
level to create what is being called in
you never the cultural quarter it
entails resources or assets owned by
district County and town and it's
creating a common vision of how all
these things can be delivered now what
we'd like to do here what I'd like to do
here is create a group of all
councillors who represent the four
Ward's in Newton Abbot to create a task
and finish group to look at how that
cultural quarter can be delivered by
working with the town with the county
and to do that I think it's fair to say
that we should ask every counselor who's
elected other than a portfolio holder
who can take part in OH&S meetings
unfortunately but invite the two
councillors who are not on onus that
counts the Bradford and counts Parker to
join with the other six councillors to
form the group testing finish group so
that group will entail with two
councillors from Bradley
the two counters from bushel the two
councillors from college and the three
councillors from the other side of the
road Melba
with the exception of mystery mrs. hook
first obviously portfolios so with it
your approval that is what this group is
about working with the town working with
a county to develop a a process
procedure of how people who work
together deliver a common objective okay
so the protocol is the output from this
roof on the same basis that we had the
other vote is there anybody who descents
from that as an approach we have a
second sorry yeah a second second second
thank you okay we have a proposal we
have a second that is to anybody that
this sense when creating this group I
have nobody indicating that as a dissent
in that case with your approval
it'll be passed as a unanimous decision
again I have nobody showing any dissent
or any disagreement with that as
approach okay let's pass unanimously
then Sarah moving on 19:14 executive
forward plan this is shown on your
computers are there any issues or coming
from this what I would ask Sarah is hph
whose projects are shown on the forward
plan can you ask them to indicate if
they look like any support or help or
any project work for the ons committee
to undertake to help them deliver they
requirements lay down in the forward
plan yes I can be forwarded to to the to
all the executive okay thank you
scooting exactly if decisions you've all
seen are there any questions about
decisions made by the executive
I'm seeing no answers no no hands raised
so take that as read you've all say any
questions item 16 the starter joint
minutes are the 16th of June are there
any questions about the report from
strata there is a an outstanding issue
that goes back some months where we all
raised the question about the funds
being charged by or being paid by
councilors for the provision of
computers that they lead to to come back
with an answer I haven't had that
response back from them yet I've had an
email do you wish that which is it the
topic that we should be raising again
about the 400 pounds you each pay I can
see a lot of lips moving but I assume
that's the case okay in which case I
will write to strata and asks for a an
update on their thoughts my ideas our
work program we've put a lot of our work
program into today we put a lot of
effort into a number of projects we'll
have the work program redefine if
anybody wishes to add some Liberty to do
so and please note that your report had
contains the forms that you will be
required to complete the submit an
application are there any other issues
that to anybody wishes to raise
I have nobody raising any any issue
although I'd ask is that those people
haven't responded about which work with
people should get involved with about
cope with 19 projects can you please get
in touch with me ASAP so we can work out
so which groups to nominate from more
allocated to are there any other
questions for the Quinta in that case I
have seen no no questions it's meeting
doors are closed at 12:33 thank you your
time and thank you thank you cheering
Thank You Chemical experiences as well
thank you
Thank You chairman
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
are you looking off Dave let's go good
okay but Trish just a quick one glad to
see back in the frame now yeah sorry you
yeah sorry I don't use I had to come
into the office and I lost totally lost
in connect internet connection at home
strata can't sort out my service
provider consortium